bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 et
sur radio france internationale notre
invité aujourd'hui et jean michel samaha
lukong décès le premier ministre de la
république démocratique du congo il est
en duplex avec nous depuis kinshasa est
avec moi pour cette interview karine
franck de rfi monsieur le premier
ministre
bonjour
oui bonjour marc et bonjour karine
monsieur le premier ministre cela fait
exactement un an que vous êtes à la
primature alors on va commencer avec la
situation dans l'est du pays des
pourparlers avec les groupes armés
actifs là bas ont commencé la semaine
dernière à nairobi est ce que vous êtes
optimiste sur les chances d'enfin mettre
un terme à des décennies de violence
vous avez parlé à des des pourparlers
que moi je considère être comme des
consultations qui se font dans le cadre
diplomatique et surtout dans le cadre de
notre adhésion bien sûr la communauté
des états de l'afrique de l'est et où
l'engagement est pris pour tous les
états membres d'assurer la sécurité de
la zone de l'est et c'est dans ce cadre
que ces consultations se font avec pour
objectif vraiment de ramener une paix et
une paix durable dans cette zone des
grands lacs mais est ce que ce n'est pas
une nouvelle fois faire une prime aux
groupes armés en leur offrant des postes
en les intégrant dans l'armée et ceci en
toute impunité non ici d'abord il
faudrait savoir qu' il ya des signes des
signaux clairs a lancé en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement bien sûr par
rapport à la population et dont ces
consultations nous voulons mettre nous
beaucoup plus en avant le programme de
désarmement et démobilisation de ces
forces négatives afin de permettre une
réinsertion sociale ça c'est notre
objectif principal longtemps
gouvernement et ce programme qui a été
mis en place a déjà ses animateurs
bientôt nous des animateurs provinciaux
est ce que nous voulons voir demain
c'est cette réinsertion là ce n'est pas
content pour premier objectif ce que
vous avez mentionné que c'est le premier
ministre parmi ces groupes rebelles
figure le m23 qui a repris ses actions
armées récemment on voit qu'il ya
toujours des escarmouches est-ce que
vous soupçonnez comme d'autres à
kinshasa le rwanda d'être à la manoeuvre
notamment en lui fournissant des armes
bon disons que le m23 qui est pris comme
tous les autres toutes les autres forces
négatif est très surveillée au niveau à
des opérations militaires qui sont
menées et nous nous savons que dans la
zone il ya beaucoup d'interactions
n'oubliez pas que nous venons d'un cycle
de plus de trente ans de violence dans
cette zone avec une prolifération
d'armes et
surtout des complicités et donc à partir
de ce moment là nous le plus important
c'est que on s'assure que ces forces
négatives soit éradiquée et je crois que
dans le cadre des consultations qui sont
faites et des échanges ont fait mention
aussi justement non seulement au
financement qu'il faut absolument
contrôler de ces groupes armés mais
aussi leur armement et donc dans ce
cadre là le m23 plus comme les autres
forces sera contrôlée mais est ce que le
rwanda est derrière le m23 est ce que
vous pouvez répondre à cette question
mais c'est le premier ministre ce sont
des échanges qui se font non seulement
avec
l'ouganda le rwanda le burundi
parce que n'oubliez pas que dans toutes
les exactions qui a eu nous avons eu des
forces qui sont venus de toutes ces
zones donc c'est normal que l'on puisse
avoir peut-être des solutions qui
peuvent être faits mais dans ce cadre là
le rwanda donne aussi ses moyens dans le
cas des échanges que nous avons par
rapport à l'ua c'est donc moi je
voudrais pas trop m'étendre trop
longtemps sur cette question parce que
j'estime que dans le cas de notre bilan
il ya beaucoup d'autres sujets que j'ai
mentionnés et sur lesquels nous pourrons
pas sûr alors vous revenez justement
d'une visite dans les provinces de l'est
d'ituri le nord kivu sont depuis un an
sous état de siège
en juin 2021 le président tshisekedi
disait à jeune afrique l'état de siège
nous réussirons c'est une question de
mois alors c'est donc bel et bien un
échec et des négociations lancées à
nairobi en sont la preuve
non pas du tout bien au contraire
d'abord ici il faut savoir que
l'opération d'état siège consiste
consistait d'abord avoir justement
d'avoir des autorités militaires mais
par la suite des opérations militaires
pour réduire la zone d'action des forces
négatives et finalement en tout cas pour
les plus virulentes les éradiquer
complètement et pour les forces
des groupes armés locaux les ramener à
par rapport aux opérations militaires à
une réinsertion comme gelée dans le
cadre du programme de désarmement et de
démobilisation et de réinsertion sociale
est donc aujourd'hui nous allons passer
à ces étapes post opération militaire
mais les opérations militaires
continuent de semer nez sur la zone et
nous sommes non seulement déterminée
mais convaincu que nous allons ramener
ce rétablissement de l'autorité de
l'état et la paix à l'est de la
république démocratique du congo mais
est-ce que vous pouvez clarifier est ce
que vous allez donc levé cet état de
siège et si oui quand
à ce stade nous avons un rapport
circonstancié qui a été fait dans le cas
de la visite que nous avons fait nous
avons eu à écouter non seulement toutes
les franges de la population de cette
zone mais aussi des opérateurs
humanitaires qui sont à nos côtés dans
les jours qui vont suivre on va pouvoir
donner une feuille de route claire par
rapport aux opérations qui sont menées
et à ce moment là toutes ces dates
seront donnés à qui de droit ça veut
dire dans le cadre des échanges que nous
avons avec l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat mais aussi tous les opérateurs qui
sont dans la zone donc l'état de siège
mais relevé monsieur le premier ministre
aux actions ou aux priorités que que
j'avoue que j'avais donnée tout à
l'heure mais dans le cas de la feuille
de route temps je viens de vous parler
je vous ai dit que il ya plusieurs
propositions qui ont été faites dont
parmi celles ci non seulement la
poursuite qu'il reste une des options
mais peut-être aussi une requalification
de la zone étant donné que les exactions
se font dans des zones beaucoup de plus
en plus précises et donc
la vraie orientation sera donné dans le
cadre de la feuille de route que nous
allons établir la présidentielle est
prévue en décembre
2023 mais dans le camp du président
certains évoquent un glissement possible
de cette date sous prétexte que le
président a perdu les deux premières
années de son mandat actuel dans des
luttes de pouvoirs avec son prédécesseur
alors le glissement et il formellement
exclue selon vous
pour nous ce n'est même pas une
possibilité j'espère en tout cas c'est à
ce moment que vous vous laisse vous
n'êtes pas laisser aller à ce que moi je
vais considérer comme une rumeur tout à
l'heure lorsque j'ai évoqué les
priorités du gouvernement j'ai fini par
cette question de des élections en
disant que pour nous c'était une
priorité aujourd'hui nous avons non
seulement un bureau qui a été installé
qui est notre interlocuteur mais avec
lequel nous avons déjà commencé les
opérations parce que le gouvernement
dans son rôle c'est d'assurer le
financement de ce processus électoral
avec comme pour objectif principal le
respect non seulement des délais et
c'est un engagement pris par le
président de la république et par le
gouvernement lorsqu'il a présenté son
programme devant l'assemblée nationale
et nous avons même d'ailleurs mentionné
car la clé de ces opérations nous
souhaitons dans le cadre des
mutualisations que nous faisons avec
deux autres services qui sont chargés de
l'identification notamment lawn ip dns
d'avoir à la clé de l'enrôlement un
fichier d'identification nationale ce
sont des opérations de mutualisation qui
sont déjà en cours le financement se
fait déjà et donc nous sommes convaincus
que dans le programme que nous avons
nous allons maintenir le cap vu que nous
sommes résolument tournés vers l'avenir
et assurer ces élections en 2023
monsieur le premier ministre
l'opposition continue cependant de
contester la composition de la
commission électorale la ceni ainsi que
de la cour constitutionnelle elle
réclame un dialogue alors est ce que
vous êtes favorable à ce dialogue pour
se mettre d'accord sur les règles du jeu
nous avons des cadres institutionnels
claire des changes je crois que le
mécanisme pour mettre en place le bureau
de la ceni passe par le parlement c'est
une procédure qui s'est fait et qui a
été respectée et donc aujourd'hui c'est
place aux élections qui vont venir et
donc évoqué une question qui pourrait
mettre à mal le processus ou peut-être
de retarder n'est pas de mise pour nous
donc je dis nous concerne en tant que
gouvernement nous nous attelons à
l'organisation des élections sont allés
sur ce volet qui est évoqué peut-être
qu'il peut y avoir d'autres cadres de
chant des changes mais ça ne sera pas à
mon sens pour remettre en cause le
processus électoral en cours
mais le risque monsieur le premier
ministre c'est que la rdc s'engage comme
à l'époque de joseph kabila sur un
processus électoral non consensuelle
avec son lot de contestations et de
violences
non d'abord je ne voudrais pas comparer
les deux époques où nous sommes dans un
contexte totalement différent
je rappelle ici que nous avons eu une
requalification de la majorité et que
dans le cadre du processus dans lequel
nous sommes
le cros des forces sont engagés par
rapport à l'union sacrée de la nation et
que en tant que gouvernement nous notre
rôle c'est d'assurer la sécurité
justement de ce processus et nous sommes
pleinement engagés là dedans
l'histoire électorale en république
démocratique du congo
montres qui a jamais eu unanimité totale
vis-à-vis du processus électoral mais le
plus important c'est que la majorité
s'assume et la sueur et que puisse
garantir une certaine transparence et
par rapport à cela je voudrais
mentionner et rappeler l'invitation de
son excellence monsieur le président de
la république non seulement la
communauté internationale mais à toutes
les forces vives en participer et donc à
partir du moment où nous aurons une
volonté claire de tous les acteurs
d'aller dans ce processus apaisé je ne
vois pas d'où viendrait non seulement la
violence ou les contestations allons de
l'impact sur la population direct de la
guerre en ukraine est ce qu'il y a un
impact direct vous avez un programme
très ambitieux mais ne risque-t-on pas
de voir des pénuries de carburant voire
des risques de famille est ce que vous
êtes inquiet que la guerre en ukraine
pourrait faire dvd rail est votre
programme économique très ambitieux
lorsque nous avons des chocs exogènes
comme ceux que nous vivons actuellement
nous avons des fortes augmentations de
prix nous sommes obligés de nous
réadapter pouvoir comme est ce que nous
faisons face à ces augmentations ou à
d'autres pénurie qui pourrait advenir
nous voulons nous profiter de je vais
dire de cette crise pour la capitaliser
et voir comment est ce que nous revenons
vers une résilience au niveau de la
république démocratique du congo surtout
dans le secteur agricole et revenir sur
la revanche du sol sur le sous sol et
donc nous sommes très engagés dans ce
schéma là nous sommes dans des reformes
un vis-à-vis du secteur agricole pour
arriver à atténuer le choc et jusque là
dans les engagements que nous avons pris
que ce soit du point de vue des recettes
que nous avons connue en 2021 où nous
avons dépassé les prévisions budgétaires
aujourd'hui sur le budget qui a été voté
pour l'année 2022 et qui a représenté
près du double de celui qui avait été
votée l'année dernière jusque là nous
nous maintenons le cap tourner vers
l'avenir et déterminés à l'atteindre et
nous sommes convaincus que la manière
dont nos recettes se comporte
actuellement vont nous permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif
la lutte contre la corruption est une
priorité vous l'avez dit mais en février
votre gouvernement a signé un accord
avec l'homme d'affaires israélien dan
gertler le qui est lui sous sanctions
américaines pour corruption
en échange de la section de l'ensemble
de ses actifs miniers et pétroliers cat
leur échappe aux poursuites judiciaires
pourquoi cette impunité
moi je ne considère pas qu'il échappe au
système judiciaire ça c'est vous qui le
dites madame moi je crois que dans la
politique ici en république démocratique
du congo
c'est de revenir sur des contrats qui
ont été un mal négocié et revenir sur
l'intérêt congolais l'intérêt de la
république démocratique du congo et dans
le cadre oui de cet objectif ici dans
les échanges que nous avons eus avec
l'homme d'affaires d'un guetteur c'était
d'abord de récupérer nos actifs miniers
et s'assurer qu'elles servent à
l'intérêt congolais au développement
congolais et nous avons dit que nous
n'allons pas le faire en allant à
l'encontre des objectifs judiciaire
parce que nous avons eu aussi justement
à échanger non seulement avec le trésor
américain ce sont des échanges qui ceux
qui continuent à se poursuivre pour dire
que dans l'engagement que nous prenons
ici l'objectif c'est ne pas d'aller à
l'encontre justement comme j'ai dit de
ses obligations judiciaires que je pense
que
c'est bien entendu et c'est clair et je
ne voudrais pas qu'on puisse mélanger
des deux questions monsieur le premier
ministre merci et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi sur sur nos deux antennes
[Musique]